today I'll stick to football mock draft
Monday returns Conor and I gotta break
down the whole first round I also get a
talk that's some draft on draft
questions a little bit of what's going
on around the league as we starts
getting ready two weeks from today I
will be in Indianapolis the 2020 NFL
Combine kicking off we're gonna have
some fun there we'll get you guys
updated when we know our exact plans to
Connor a quiet weekend thank God not a
whole lot going on no not a whole lot
going on I'll say this though Matt it
was fun to have some football this
weekend with the XFL in a debut weekend
that I thought went as well as anyone
could have asked for I think of course
with the XFL the questions will always
be is this sustainable is there
longevity in this but along the lines of
having football at this time of February
it was pretty fun for what it was yeah
let's just start there I didn't get a
chance to watch a ton of it you could
probably tell my voice is a little off
my son still has the flu so I was on dad
mode all weekend but what I did get to
see in between trying to make sure he
takes tylenol over four hours was that I
do like the pace better I think there
are some things the NFL could adopt the
kickoff was amazing to me and I noticed
something mellow when I talked a lot
about on our local radio show that we do
sorry I thought it was the podcast it
wasn't but it's so much fun because that
pause that you have to wait it's like
that old electronic football game then
I'm probably the only one old enough to
have remembered playing where there's
just this anticipation and you can't
move until the the returner catches the
ball I loved that aspect of it I think
you know like the interviews on the
sidelines no way the NFL is never gonna
do that like they should any be cool but
I haven't saw former and current players
and coaches being like there's no way
like you miss a field goal you come off
and there's silent reporter asking the
kicker like what was going through your
mind why did you miss this kick right
away
I don't yeah I don't see the NFL ever go
into that it would be it would be
interesting but I think professional
athletes are just not gonna want to give
that kind of access as far as you know I
didn't see a ton of innovation in terms
of like rule changes or even like review
that I think the NFL is gonna have to
adopt one thing I did catch the little
Bud Light sticker on the back of the
helmets I wouldn't be shocked if the NFL
adopted that because that's just smart
advertising and I wasn't even looking
for it I just it was just like they had
a shot of it I was like oh hey there's a
Bud Light sticker on that guy's helmet I
think that's one thing we could see the
NFL adopt yeah a couple of things I was
a really big fan of I agree with you
with the kickoff rule because it finds a
way to reduce the injury risk of the
collisions of the kickoffs while still
making it exciting and I saw a lot of
people on Twitter saying well the style
of the kickoff this eliminates the big
play ability it has I saw plenty of big
returns this weekend in the XFL where I
didn't really agree with that I saw guys
getting to the outside getting to the 50
yard line
I thought it was really really well done
I love love love the after touchdown
point conversions whether it's one two
or three points I have no idea why you'd
ever go for one if you go for two it
gives you more room on the fields and
obviously the risk was very very minimal
I liked taking away the kicking game on
the point conversions that was and the
fact that their strategy to it deciding
whether you know if it's nine-point lead
Matt it's a one-possession game now
there will be traditionalists that don't
want to get away from that at the
National Football League but I think for
a league like the XFL it was phenomenal
at the player interaction with the fans
is something they have to do and I think
they did a really good job of it I do
agree that the access it's like they
were given full access and they ran too
far with it I don't need to know every
single play that's coming before the
snap right and I also don't need to hear
from the kicker after he misses a kick
but I thought it was really really
exciting and well done and most
importantly I did get the feel that this
is a Developmental League where this can
create more back end of the roster
players for the middle of the NFL season
that put out tape during the XFL season
that'll stay in shape ready to go and I
will say I know we sat on the Friday
show this was the Guardians podcast
after seeing some of the people
supporting the Guardians she kept
pulling the plug on it and I actually
said this Saturday morning before
kickoff I was you know what I'm gonna
have to stay true to my roots
I'm a Roughnecks fan you know I I want
to run and shoot you got a rep a Texas
team and again I mean Dan Ravel got a
Guardians Jersey I'm out on that so I
love the all-black but I think it you
know win it with a new league you got to
pick your team wisely so I
I am officially switching and did so
before kick-off Saturday I'm now a
Roughnecks fan yeah and you know some of
the players in it that we were excited
for did like Cardale Jones
I thought played very well you know
classic Cardell where all the armed
talent in the world PJ Walker was very
good McAvoy was very good it was a
league where I'll say this for how much
time they've had and the level of
quarterbacks that they have is the face
of the league I thought the offenses
were actually somewhat in sync a lot
more than I expected
yeah let's move on to the NFL that's
your XFL talk for the week we'll have
more next week today Monday as we're
recording this Monday morning depending
on when you listen to it too talking
about Lois hip CT is today now this is
seen as a a milestone in his rehab we
are three months out from injury we are
two weeks before the combine so I
actually like that they scheduled it now
they will there will be no surprises
when they get to Indy which i think is
huge you want to know internally where
are we at and fortuitous al I have no
idea and I don't think anyone possibly
could not even Adam Schefter if he gets
the CT scans from some rogue hospital
employee I don't think anyone has the
idea what to expect right now I know we
said a month ago that his doctors
appointment New York went very well to
the point that he felt confident
declaring and his agent Leigh Steinberg
came out said hey he's gonna have a full
recovery we're gonna be good to go I
think we'll hear maybe this afternoon on
Monday but definitely by Tuesday we'll
have some information as far as how that
CT scan looked today yeah that's I mean
it's gonna be huge
obviously like you said Matt this is
something that will not be made
available to the general public pluck
but I think when we get to Indy you'll
hear plenty of rumors about how
comfortable teams are with to it and you
might hear some fake stuff for teams
that hope he might fall down the board
to number five the Miami Dolphins so I
think the draft cycle around two is
obviously one of the most interesting
storylines of this entire offseason
because of the health risk and until we
get to see him out on the field working
out going through a full workout going
through a full cycle of throws whenever
that would be I think people are always
going to be a little skeptical on his
return but
no personally for me I'm very very
excited to see to and make this comeback
and I would say for me if tool were
healthy and I know that's the it's the
hugest if in the world because he's had
three significant injuries in two years
if you were healthy I think we would be
talking about a battle for number one
quarterback in this class I'm here at
golf and Carson Wentz you know we'd be
back to the or Baker Mayfield Sam darn
old it would be more of those
conversations of man you're almost just
splitting hairs which style do you like
better from the two quarterbacks just I
do think with two uh he got hit with two
of like the draft cycles worst
nightmares
he was so good early that we started
over that oh say wheat not nothing three
of us here the people started to
overlook him like okay he's good let's
pull him apart for every little flaw and
then he got hurt so you forget how good
he was so it was like he was over
processed over evaluated and then he got
hurt and Joe borough has a historic
season I think people have forgotten how
good to it is but we'll see where the
hip is at again today CT scan two weeks
the combine and he's gonna get poked
prodded and pulled in a million
directions there and there will be a
cleaner look not just at the hip but
also at the ankle which has never talked
about I'll say this Matt and you
probably noticed this as well when we
got to spend time with Jerry Judy
Jerry's definitely you know a more quiet
reserved guy which isn't always the case
for super star receivers but definitely
got that vibe from him something that
really lit him up when we were talking
to him or got him really excited was
talking about his teammates and one of
those was specifically to us so I think
that's something you're gonna hear
across the board in this draft cycle and
you'll hear it for Joe burrow to you
already have is how much his teammates
and coaches and everyone around the
University of Alabama adores this guy
and it's something that's only gonna
help sell him to teams even more going
forward Oh without a doubt now more
quarterback talk and I keep trying to
tell people when it comes to mock drafts
this time of year everything is based on
what we think will happen in free agency
but more than any year I've been doing
this ten years more than any year free
agency is going to have a monster effect
on the NFL Draft because of the
quarterback position we're waiting to
see what happens with Tom Brady dak
Prescott Phillip Rivers Drew Brees
Teddy Bridgewater Jameis Winston Ryan
Tannehill there
seven starting quarterbacks we're gonna
be free agents this year and Michael
Irvin I don't have II meant to do it but
he dropped a grenade on the NFL world
when he said that he had talked to
people in Miami who said people with the
Cowboys in Miami who said that it has
been discussed at least bringing in Tom
Brady and then trying to tag and trade
dak Prescott I think that would be a
very Cowboys thing to do and if you're
trying to win a Super Bowl within the
next two years that part of it makes
sense but moving on from dak Prescott
who just had a phenomenal season I think
what like 4,000 yards 30 touchdowns you
had a phenomenal season you bring in a
quarterback of Mike McCarthy who you're
hoping can capitalize on dak strengths
they're trying to build this team around
him and you throw it all away
for two years of Tom Brady again Jerry
Jones very impulsive it has worked
sometimes in the past and with Jimmie
Johnson other times it hasn't I don't
see how this is a smart football move
from a marketing perspective it would be
phenomenal from a long-term view this is
a horrendous move I mean Tom Brady is
going to be playing at 43 years old next
year while dak Prescott will be playing
at 27 they both you know turn John turns
243 this summer dak turns 27 this
upcoming summer but Matt are we even
sure right now that Tom Brady gives you
a better chance at a Super Bowl Ben Zack
Prescott because I'm not after watching
this season I thought dak was very very
good extremely good and that's not to
take away from Tom but you have an
ascending young quarterback that's been
there and this might just be complete
nonsense for the Cowboys fans listening
that are going why are we even
addressing this I mean when it's a rumor
from Michael Irvin you no matter how
crazy it is we're gonna address it but
yeah I'm with you all the way that just
get the deal done with dak I mean he was
very very good this year he keeps
getting better you have something in
place there in Dallas that you know
you're building chemistry for the long
haul and I just think that when you have
a young franchise quarterback like that
you should not even entertain these kind
of things oh I absolutely agree Dudley
should not
shouldn't would with the Dallas Cowboys
could be a little different but I think
what you haven't dak who like you said
is young and he is what the league is
moving toward I mean he's not Lamar
Jackson as a runner but he can get
things done with his legs I think we're
seeing that become such a huge part of
offenses he's accurate he's smart he's a
great leader he just threw for forty
nine hundred yards and I think you look
at Dallas and say Amari Cooper's like
good but not great Michael Gallup is an
ascending player you know Jason Witten
it's hide in like come on he needs more
help around him I think he also the
offensive scheme got a little bit stale
and then even like Elmore coming in this
year like first two weeks they looked
amazing that dropped off a little bit so
I I think you have to go with dak the
bigger I think question is why hasn't
the deal gotten done yet you've known
this was coming you've had negotiations
for like a year now so somebody's gonna
have to fold here and I'm betting it
will be Dallas and one thing I wanted
sorry go ahead full if you fold for
Ezekiel Elliott you might have fold for
the quarterback like that's where my
priorities are mixed up and I know just
like looking at this that Stephen Jones
has said they're all in on dak Mike
McCarthy's all in on dak Michael Irvin
is you know kind of said oh it wasn't
like that serious but the thing is like
if you got the deal done with your
running back I really hope you could
figure it out with the quarterback which
is so much more valuable I always felt
like they did this backward there should
have done dak I agree and then Zeke but
we're not in the locker room dealing
with the politics there so maybe is
different now one thing I did want to do
before we get into mock draft Monday
let's talk about some players that went
up the board for me over the weekend
there was a little more controversy than
there should have been on Twitter but
that's Twitter for you about this but
this time of year as you know because
I've seen you tweeting out many of the
same things is that we have been on the
road since August 19th I've been I've
personally been gone every other weekend
since August 19th so when I'm home on
weekends I have my son I'm single dad
have a six year old take care him and
also trying to get caught up on players
because like until the Senior Bowl all
my focus was on seniors and then after
the senior ball you tend to switch to
juniors and try to watch those guys
leading up to the combine so for me this
means guys move up guys move down three
players I want to highlight that are
moving up for me the first one with
Stanford Samuels the coroner from
Florida
and I was very transparent about this
when I washed him in November was like
yeah I don't know about this guy but the
more I have watched the more I think you
see the traits and so the like not
looking at the production or necessarily
how he did any give it a play but
looking at the traits for Samuels I'm
really intrigued he seeks to he's 185 I
thought he moved a lot better as I got
to Game five Game six than I expected
he's gonna be a little bit scheme
specific but when I look at the tier of
corners in round 2 you know guys like
a.j Terrell I would put Stanford Samuels
right below that I think cam Dan slurs
gonna be in that conversation I really
liked what I saw from him and I think in
this class where there's not that great
shelf at tier 2 in corner I think he has
a chance to move into that spot be a top
50 pick along the lines like jaylen
Johnson I would put Jalen a little ahead
of him AJ true a little bit ahead of him
but I think he's right there with guys
like Trayvon Diggs Noah from Auburn
camera Dantzler so probably like a top
60 pick for me yeah I mean when you look
at Samuels you always go back to why he
was you know a five-star recruit and the
length and the athleticism so I think he
almost feels like one of those prospects
that is still that ball of clay a really
really raw player that definitely
surprised this show when he declared
early but I think when you look at the
state of the program at Florida State
and you look at how NFL teams will value
what he offers at the cornerback
position it does make sense whether he
got a return to you know school great or
not something that we don't personally
know right now but I'm with you Matt I'm
excited to watch more of him and same
way I like that you brought up the name
jaylen Johnson because he feels like now
for a while that first corner off the
board in the second round of mock drafts
and conversations was Jeff Gladney glad
he's been pushed in the back end of
round one because you have a lot of
players that go back to school or fall
now Johnson seems to be the the guy for
everyone in round two yeah another one
moving up for me again a guy locally for
me Jordan Elliot with Mizzou I was like
at Mizzou was so bad this year I know
that's not I seem that a lot of people
nationally they just weren't fun to
watch and so I kind of put off Jordan
Elliott I really like him I think he is
up there with guys like Justin mata
bouquet I'm he's
probably and that would never Nevile
Gallimore from oklahoma to guys that
were seniors that I really enjoyed in
this class
I think he's gonna push to be in that
category of a round to pick and Jordan
Elliott probably not a guy a lot of
people know he transferred from Texas
but really good athlete at six four
three fifteen and he could play as a
three technique he's gonna offer some
versatility if he has to come out play
as a five technique on first and second
down but I think when you look at the
interior g-line class it is like Raekwon
davis Jordan Elliot Neville Gallimore
just amount of bouquet or the four guys
that are maybe mid to late second-round
picks but they're kind of clustered
together for me right now and honestly
it's just a matter of having more time
and more access to game tape to break
those guys down but starting to get a
little more excited about that tier two
into your D line class would you
consider it basically Kinlaw and brown
are in that Tier one and then you get
the Ross black lock kind of range in the
middle yeah that's kind of how it's
looking for me as well I think Kinlaw
and Brown is closer than I expected it
to be while you've been watching you
know a lot of players on the defensive
end of things I've been trying to catch
up on the offensive line and the wide
receivers and when we were in mobile we
heard a lot of potential around once off
for Brandon IU and then he didn't get to
practice that week it took some of the
buzz out of things I've gone back and
watched his end of season games so all
the beginning of the season like you
said we were always on the road then you
go back to the big games at the end of
the season specifically against Oregon
and I get it the explosiveness with the
ball in his hands he's one of the better
run after catch kind of players in this
class now
I don't know if he'll be round one in
this draft that would be tough for me
because listen we might see Judy lamb
rugs those kind of guys fall down the
board and that only pushes someone like
I uke but if you're looking for a day to
player similar to how me call Hardman
was valued last year in the spread heavy
NFL offenses a guy that you can find
different ways to get the ball in his
hands you could send him vertically he
can return punts I really like what I
saw from the speedster and I who it's
funny you mentioned that Oregon game
because and I was over here typing
pulling up my notes he in that game so
Oregon has two defenders that I really
like the edge rusher Thibodeau and in
Lenoir the corner and I absolutely
worked Lenoir in that game and badly
that was the one game where you're like
holy
[ __ ] like this guys yuck he's a player
because you can get like hot sometimes
like how man is he see really that good
or is he just making two to three
explosive plays a game the stick in your
memory
he worked Lenore and Lenore's a good
player that's no disrespect to him he
worked him in that game my comp for iuck
has been Sammy Watkins
I still feel real I like that a lot yeah
and one more guy I want to point out
because I think there's a good chance
that he goes to New York your New York
Jets I'm not sure how you feel about
this but I love Caleb on Chaisson and I
know we've been talking about him on the
show for two years you guys might be
tired of it
but just getting a chance to watch him
more this week and I know the production
wasn't there I think you only had three
sacks this year my goodness can he bend
and I think when you look at this class
edge rushers you know guys like a JEP
Anessa
I don't even the AJ is truly an edge I
think he's more of like a big defensive
end who's gonna kick inside some I mean
say it's chase young and then it's chase
on as far as guys that can truly Bend
and get around the corner I mean you
dork gross Matos is gonna be in that
conversation as well but again he's
another guy that's really filling out a
bigger dude I just think chase ons got a
chance to just shoot way way up I don't
want to give this away too much cuz BR
will get mad at me because they they're
tired of me spoiling my big board on the
podcast he's gonna be in the top 15 for
me when I do an update I just you know I
said it on the show earlier in the year
when I love a guy I'm just gonna love
the guy regardless of whatever guys in
the NFL say chase I was one of those
dudes I just love watching him play I
was talking about that with our buddy
jacob hester on his radio show down in
Baton Rouge on Friday we went through a
lot of the LSU prospects and when you
get to chase on the thing is watch the
tape against good offensive tackle
prospects and look for the out of box
score production I think one of those is
you brought up that Bill ability to bend
Matt look at it against Alex Leatherwood
who went back to school for Alabama
before he did that and before that game
we were consistently talking about him
in the top 20 of our early mock draft
Mondays and I thought chase on got him
really good
he hit Isiah Wilson with that spin move
I mean you saw the very pass rush plan
down the stretch at the end of the
season we're number one like you said
this is not a deep edge class and just
the
traits that Chaisson has and i think you
bring up the Jets and a lot of people
will be scared well you said these
things about your Chi polite they're on
a different world of character a
completely different world so that's the
one thing you have to know with Chaisson
as he rises in this draft class yes and
a dude who I think we talked about it
before you want to see guys play well in
big games Alabama Georgia Oklahoma were
chased on its three best games that's
right so that's what you want to see
from a player let's take a break we come
back the Bengals are on the clock you
know who the pick is gonna be but we're
gonna go through all 32 picks of round
one for you anyway here are mock draft
London these Cincinnati Bengals are on
the clock at number one overall when I
minded release a mock draft without
trades
although Connor you as the GM I don't
think you would even probably listen to
a trade at this point for number one
overall I would not I know people have
discussed this at times what is the
price for the Bengals I don't think
there is one this is a franchise that
has basically had a miracle fall into
their lap where the top quarterback in
this draft is an Ohio kid that can
really turn this franchise around I
believe he can now they do need to build
around him they do need to spend money
and care about winning football games
but for the Bengals you're not moving
out of this pick it is Joe borough
number one overall and you're gonna get
tired of this too because number two
overall Washington Redskins it is chase
young address from Ohio State and I will
say this I've seen a lot of people on
Twitter and I've had a lot of people ask
me this would Washington trade out of
this spot or what would it cost I think
Washington would have to want to trade
out that's what people forget it takes
two to tango just like a free agency
like a team can want to keep a player
but the player has to want to stay there
and I think with Washington sure Miami
could call an offer the world to come up
to number two for two uh but do the
Redskins want to trade out I don't think
they do I think around Rivera's gonna
look at Chase young and say how did I
get this lucky and like jobber oh you're
getting a somewhat local guy who is a
high character player who can come in
and really change the fortunes of this
team the interval is copycat league
everyone's gonna look at San Francisco
and say look what Nick Bosa did and look
what they did with five first rounders
on that d-line Washington would have
four first rounders plus Matt Ryan itis
who is a very good
the model is there chase young is
different than Nick Bosa I think he's
probably closer to Miles Garrett in
terms of the type of player that he is
because he's not exceptional against the
run that could change and with a little
bit of technique help he's first step
quickness is as good as you're gonna get
whether it's Garrett clowny Khalil Mack
he's in that category in terms of first
step quickness in the panic the heat
causes four offensive linemen so I think
chase young is close to a done deal at
number two overall if you're Washington
number three the Detroit Lions and
they're hoping that is not a done deal
and that Washington trades that so they
get chase young but I don't know if
they'll be that lucky this pick for me
is Jeff CUDA another Ohio State player
so the top three players in this mantra
have all played at Ohio State before I
think for little Lyons there's a couple
of factors in play here Matt what is
gonna happen with Darius slay number two
accout is just a top-five player in this
draft overall Matt Patricia who you know
has been able to keep his job I think
you look at those New England offenses
over the years they value having a
number-one shutdown corner and that is
exactly what Jeff Okuda is so for the
Lions here I know there will be people
set and when we get the trades that'll
be this will be the team that's in the
conversation of trading we're not there
right now and I think you look at it
this is the best possible pick for them
if they stay in this spot you're right
Patriots have had I mean Revis Butler
Gilmore they need good corners that suta
mix how they run the defense since
they're number four the New York Giants
again this is becoming almost wrote at
this point because we feel like they're
gonna go offensive tackle no I do hear
that Nate's older could come back at
least for one more year but offensive
tackles still in need at right tackle
it's still a future need this is why I
have Jedrek wills going here from
Alabama he could come in a play right
tackle
he could play left tackle and have
solder switch sides gives you a lot of
versatility I know there's been a lot of
talk about Makai Becton certain allowed
to talk about Tristan Murph's Andrew
Thomas and I feel like we've said this a
billion times but you know for me it's
just wills the best tackle in this class
and that's no disrespect to some of the
other guys I mentioned who are really
good players wills is just the best I
think his recovery speed his technique
he's accuracy when shooting his hands
now I will be in
what he measures in it in two weeks
because we are gonna see teams as always
panic when it comes to arm links so that
would be key for wills but I'll give you
the Giants you got Daniel Jones you got
sacrum Barkley you got some good young
receivers you want to build this offense
around you got to do that by protecting
everybody upfront wills there's gonna be
talk about Isaiah Simmons here I
personally think that's too early for a
player who whether he's a linebacker or
a safety I think on talent he's top five
but when it comes to positional value
guys like Simmons are gonna get knocked
down a little bit yeah Wilson its here
of his own and you got to protect annual
Jones I mean like we keep saying you one
way to you know reduce that fumbling
issue make sure he doesn't get hit so
add Jedrek wills at for number five the
Miami Dolphins this is the dream
scenario for them the quarterback that
they want is there at number five and to
it's hung by Lowa I do think when all is
said and done the Dolphins will trade up
they have a lot of ammo two second-round
picks a couple other first-round picks
but in this mock draft no one takes two
of their so he falls to them it almost
feels like right now Matt it would be a
surprise if tua ends up in anything
except a Dolphins Jersey on draft night
but the only problem with that is
considering the entire league knows that
I'm curious to watch if any of these
teams behind them get ultra aggressive
to jump them to take him and I do think
by the time we get to April we say this
about your jets you know they were
sitting at six and we're like you're
gonna have to move up you're gonna have
to move up and they did I think with the
Dolphins we're probably just waiting for
those milestones of the CT scan for to
the combine and I think the talk is
gonna heat up here's what happens to the
combine to is we're gonna know the
medicals and Chris Grier is gonna you
know run into John Robinson and Bob
Quinn excuse me be like hey let's start
what's it gonna take to come up to three
we have 18 we have 24 you know what's it
gonna take
excuse me we have 18 and and 26 what's
it gonna take to get to 3 you know if we
throw them 26 and 5 is that gonna get us
to 3 I think those conversations are
gonna start because you're right the
Lions can just dangle them over the fire
basically and make them pay something to
come up and get the guy and number 6 the
LA Chargers and another team that needs
a quarterback
I think Justin Harbor is the guy here
for them and this isn't just a
consolation prize
Herbert we didn't talk a lot about him
over the last year because we were so
fascinated with to uh burrow and the
rise especially of jobber Oh Justin
Herbert really turned things around his
senior year now they're still giving
things that you don't like he doesn't
always get to second third read cleanly
he does over throw a little bit I think
you can clean up some of the mechanics
there but Herbert is worthy of a top ten
pick in my opinion because he plays
quarterback arm is their athleticism
they're a lot of the stuff that we heard
a year ago when he went back to school
about might not be a great leader kind
of a different dude I will say a lot of
that talk has quieted down I think he's
really worked hard to establish himself
more as a vocal leader more of a locker
room guy for the Chargers you need a
quarterback you need to sell tickets
I think Justin Herbert fits really well
with what you have there in Keenan Allen
what you have in and Mike Williams
Austin Eckler this offense could be
pretty explosive with Herbert's arm I
love that landing spot for Herbert and
as we always said if he's not ready to
go right away you do have Tyrod Taylor
under contract on a cheap deal for one
more year there and tie rods been in
that spot before with Baker Mayfield ooh
you know how his character is and how
he'll handled that number seven the
Panthers here Matt rules Panthers
I think Matt they are gonna slow build
this thing I think a lot of people are
sitting there wondering are the Panthers
an option to take a quarterback are they
going to be ultra aggressive when you
have a coach that is on a six seven year
deal and you know that this thing is a
long long foundational kind of rebuild
here and I'm not saying it's good they
have a lot of talent on offense you have
McCaffrey of DJ more you have players
but they don't need to panic and take a
quarterback here and I think that's why
they go offensive line at seven and this
is Makai Becton from Louisville this is
the sweet spot for him I know he's been
one of the biggest risers over this last
month and when you look at the Panthers
offensive line yes they took Greg little
last year they traded up for Greg little
and around to I don't know if they're
gonna come into this year betting the
house that Greg little is a franchise
left tackle and even if he pans out
Becton is somebody that you can go play
on the right side or you move little to
the right side you need to stack the
deck with good offensive linemen forever
the future quarterback
this team is and if it's Cam Newton this
year we know how important it is to
protect that guy I think Derek Browns
another intriguing player here depending
on what they do in free agency and I'll
say what Becton I know there's a lot of
juice on this guy lately and I think
weird I have 21 overall maybe on my
board I think of the offensive linemen
so if we put wills Thomas wharfs Becton
in a group together he is the one that
scares me the most Becton is you could
read I feel like the other guys like
andrew thomas worst case scenario is
really good guard trista wharfs worst
case scenario is a really good guard
Becton he doesn't hit man like it it
could be it could be a pretty big fall
off for him now I do I love the upside
there's a ton of it there the way he
moves it his size is probably not
natural but he is for me that if you
just want to talk biggest boom or bust
tackle out of the top tier I think it is
Becton which is why I mean he's mine
number three or four offensive tackle in
this class number a 25th yeah overall
number eight the Arizona Cardinals
speaking of Tristan worth this is where
I have him come off the board at DJ
Humphries is a free agent the Cardinals
gotta do something upfront
I know we've said before we don't know
how Kliff Kingsbury will value the
offensive line I think he values keeping
Kyler murray healthy because that's his
dude tristan wharfs helps them out
immediately like I just said whether you
play him at right tackle where he was at
Iowa left tackle where I think he could
play in the NFL if you move him inside I
think he's Zach Martin Brandon Scherff
he's a really really good guard Tristram
or whoever wherever you want to play
this dude he's gonna be a big time
factor as a rookie and the Cardinals
need a lot of help up front I think he's
my second favorite offensive lineman in
this class Matt to be honest with you I
look at wills and I think he's in his
own tier and I understand there might be
concerns with wharfs at tackle but
number one you know just like Jonah
Williams last year I'm drafting him to
be a tackle and I do think you have all
pro level guard play there as well so I
look at worse I think the floor is very
very high and I'm a big fan of his
number nine the Jacksonville Jaguars
this is a team that can go offensive
line here with an Andrew Thomas but I'm
actually gonna look on the defensive
side of the ball
I don't think talbin Smith is coming
back and I see Isiah Simmons here some
that can play so many different roles
for this Jacksonville defense him and
miles Jack that'd be a really really fun
group to watch together and this
exciting front seven for Jacksonville
here I don't think he goes top five but
I do think a lot of people will value
him as a top five player so for
Jacksonville at nine here to not only
solve a need but to get that type of
level talent it's just incredible return
and value on this pick yeah I mean I say
send miss give me all those guys we all
love and it's there's me I think the
only argument is gonna be where do you
play him and I think play safety I think
could play some weak side backer
there's a mold for him to fit in this
Jacksonville defense now number 10
overall we have the Cleveland Browns who
could go a ton of directions obviously
see what Andrew berry the new GM does
with some of the players that they've
acquired over the past couple years the
if olivia Vernon's let go this could be
a ke LaVon chase on landing spot if Joe
sherbert walks in for agency could
Patrick Queen go here I'm gonna go with
the chalk pic here Andrew Thomas
offensive line from Georgia I think if
John Dorsey made one big mistake in
terms of personnel it was that they
didn't upgrade the offensive line I
think they really put all their eggs in
the Trent Williams basket and when that
didn't happen they got stuck with no
plan at left tackle Andrew Thomas like
we just said even if you envision that
he's a guard he's gonna be an excellent
guard prospect I think you can look at
him at Georgia we talked about it
earlier there were games that like
against a sophomore I thought he got
worked a little bit there are a lot of
other games the SEC for the last two
years where he was a top-tier performer
so I think what Andrew Thomas he's
getting overthought a little bit like
you just said Conor like Jonah Williams
last year where it's like you okay we've
watched you for three years now let's
overthink it for that long you were
great at left tackle at Georgia I know
he's got a boxy build I think for the
Browns he could come in play that lat
left tackle spot keep Baker clean allow
him time to step up in the pocket and
get the ball downfield to those amazing
targets they have a receiver 11 the New
York Jets tough spot for them guess what
all four top offensive linemen are gone
this will raise a lot of questions what
do the Jets do when all is said and done
I think they're gonna end up with one of
those top four offensive linemen I think
the board will shake out a little
differently than this year I
don't think they'll get wills but a
Becton Worf Sir Thomas I think we'll be
there at 11 when all is said and done if
they're not I have no justifiable
argument Matt to not take Jerry Judi
here for Sam's Arnold I can't do it
maybe Joe Douglas can if I was a betting
man I would say the Jets plan is
offensive linemen in round one wide
receiver in round two at 49 I would bet
the house on that something like that is
their plan I can't pass on Jerry Judy
they don't have a number one wide
receiver
if Robbie Anderson leaves they don't
have a number two wide receiver
your quarterback Sam's Arnold needs
somebody reliable to throw the ball to I
just once again if Judy is there at 11
and the top four offensive linemen are
gone and it comes down to Kayla van
chase on verse Josh Jones verse Jerry
Judy it's a no-brainer to me yeah I love
Judy and I think the argument against
the Jets gonna receive around one it's
just always been nothing they don't need
it it's just a Joe Douglas isn't a
receiver guy he's not gonna do early
we'll see if he's receiver guy with no
tackles from the board 12 the Las Vegas
Raiders I think they take the best
receiver on the board here that is CD
Lane from Oklahoma he's gonna get picked
apart at the combine because he might
not run that well and I think I mean
I've said it before his route tree is
underdeveloped doesn't mean he can't do
things just means he wasn't asked to so
I think that is one of the questions was
CD but turn the tape on man for two
years he was the best receiver in the
big 12 and was unstoppable he's physical
catch radius is enormous for a guy who's
not that big he plays like he's mad at
everyone in the world which I love about
his game CD lamb to to the Raiders
almost had to Oakland that's gonna take
a while to get used to see Dee lay up to
the Raiders give Derek Carr a true
number one receiver and let's see what
he's got
yeah give Tom Brady at sure number one
Roger see the Colts here we're going
quarterback the Colts fans love this
pick Jordan love from Utah State I
personally would not make this pick I
think Jordan love is a gigantic gamble
in the top 20 selections but I will say
this for Indianapolis
I think witcha Kobe perset under
contract for one more year and you need
that developmental year for Jordan love
they are one of the team
that the fit here does make a lot of
sense and would not surprise me but once
again with the if I was betting my
future on it I'm still skeptical and
scared of taking guys like Jordan love
Jacob Eason even Justin Herbert a little
bit if your name is not Joe burrow or to
Otunga by Lowa right this quarterback
class gets a little scary but teams got
you got to take risk if you want to sit
at the big-boy table I could also see
Chris Ballard just bring in Phillip
Rivers in you know for like two years
a veteran court if we're making this
pick in what five weeks I mean I would
not be shocked if for Allah go well
we're drafting this offensive lineman to
protect this four year old quarterback
exactly right number fourteen speaking
of quarterbacks to Bay Buccaneers I
don't know what I just truly I don't
know what they're gonna do with Jameis
Winston a free agent I think that
conversations probably still being had
internally no quarterback in this class
other than Justin Herbert better fits
Tampa Bay and Bruce Arians than Jacob
Eason big body can stand in the pocket
take the hits great arm for that
vertical passing attack I don't know
that he'll be better than Jameis Winston
I actually think they're a lot alike in
terms of decision making some of the
plays they make that will drop your jaw
than some of the plays they make that
make you want to punch a wall I think
they're very similar in that way but
Jacob Eason definitely fits the mold of
what Bruce Arians once if they move on
from from Jameson free-agency
Eason is gonna be the guy that wins the
combine throwing TV award like
everyone's gonna be watching the
quarterbacks thrown there in a bag holy
[ __ ] look at this guy throw the problem
is Matt when he's on the field it's a
lot more than just throwing I mean Josh
Allen did that too I I can't remember if
you were with us I think yeah it was me
you a Melo at lunch Josh Allen started
throwing and we were like holy [ __ ] like
yeah I'm like yeah I mean even like
mahomes
you know when you watched him throw it
was oh damn Josh Allen was just been in
the ball Jacob Eason is gonna be on that
level - without a doubt fifteen the
Denver Broncos back to offensive line
here because I do think they need to
upgrade this unit I have Josh Jones here
from Houston they have a young
quarterback Andrew block that they need
to protect I do think Josh Jones needs
to get a little stronger in his base but
you always bring up the comparison to
Andre
Matt this is a guy with length light
feet and past protection he's somebody
that if you develop he can be your
franchise tackle for a long time the
reason I stayed away from this pick for
the Jets is I do think on the offensive
line they're gonna be looking for a very
very strong tough run blocker to get
that run game going for Adam GaSe
offense in Sam's arnold's I don't know
if Jones is on that level yet but for
Denver and that potentially high octane
passing attack they're building over
there I really like this landing spot
yeah he's a dancing bear he's not
necessarily a mauler number 16 the
Atlanta Falcons we had Thomas dementia
off on the show and one thing that I've
learned about Thomas over the long time
I've been doing this job is he values
character really highly in his
evaluations Caleb I chase on has
character we rockin that 18 for LSU we
know how important that is he also has
that lettis ISM and he has up side big
Beasley is gone the Falcons tweeted it
out themselves they're not bringing him
back
I think Chaisson fits what they want to
do defensively he also fits that model
of person they want to put in their
locker room so chase on a little bit of
a fall here I'm surprised he was still
in the board so I jumped all over it
chase on a six team to the Falcons and
we'll take a break and come back Conner
gets to be on the clock at 17 with the
Dallas Cowboys and a lot of free agents
that you got to replace their Dallas
Connor you are up man the Dallas Cowboys
at 17 overall you could go almost any
position here how does it the
quarterback and it would make sense yeah
I think there's a lot on the table here
a lot of cowboys fans are probably gonna
scream because Derek Brown and Sean
Kinlaw are still on the board here but
I'm gonna go safety for the Cowboys I
think this is a position they
desperately need to upgrade and I really
like Xavier McKinney from Alabama in
this spot for a while that would have
been grants help it I thought McKinney
was drastically a better player this
year I loved his play speed especially
his pursuit to the football he could do
a lot of different things whether it's
in coverage whether it's against the run
we've pretty much seen a complete
package player from McKinney and for the
Cowboys I would have no problem taking a
dark brown or Javon Kinlaw here but a
lot of this pick is going to matter of
how they attack free agency with what
cap space they have left after figuring
out negotiations with dak Prescott
obvious
Byron Jones and Amari Cooper are set to
be free agents so a lot is on the table
for them here but they have to get a
dude at the safety position Matt I'll
say with McKinney he is my top safety
like by far in this class I compared him
to Justin Simmons I think there's a
little Minka to his game I started to do
school to school comparisons but man he
has range he can blitz he could play
free safety or strong safety I really
like McKinney Cowboys fans should be
excited about that number 18 the Miami
Dolphins we gave them two at five and
then there was a run on offense two
tackles which is probably the worst case
scenario for Miami I'm gonna reach here
a little bit though because they
desperately need a left tackle after
trading Laremy Tunsil I'm gonna give
them Austin Jackson from USC a guy who
has high ceiling player really high
ceiling I think the floor is a little
bit low though he needs to develop we
saw him struggle to handle the power of
AJ epinet in the bowl game but
throughout his career in the pac-12 he
handled speed really well so Austin
Jackson you know not I don't think he's
at the Josh Jones level but he would be
the you know the sixth ranked tackle on
my board which in this year's class is a
pretty good place to be yeah you're
seeing it here that's your two tackles
are starting to fly up into the first
round because of the demand 19 the Las
Vegas Raiders here they get a wide
receiver earlier in this draft and see
deal and they got to be thrilled about
that now they get a linebacker here on
Kenneth Murray
they need a player for the middle of
this defense that has range
that's nasty that can be a leader
Kenneth Murray is a day one starter at
linebacker room with no Isaiah Simmons
on the board here this is the pick for
them right now and I think with Murray
we're gonna see Murray and Queen really
be those two guys who I was torn between
you know it's just what what do you want
they're so similar I think Murray is a
little bit better against the run Queens
a little bit better in space so it's
what do you want from those two guys
they're ranked incredibly close on my
board it comes down to scheme fit a
little bit number 20 the Jacksonville
Jaguars earlier in this draft you gave
them Isaiah Simmons like you said telev
in Smith probably not coming back I'm
gonna have them replace here another guy
who got shipped off by Tom Coughlin
that's jaylen Ramsey says CJ Henderson
from Florida is the pick we talked about
this on the Friday show Henderson is
locked in as my number two corner in
this
he's actually another player that is
moving up for me the only thing I
wondered about was you know lacking
contacting coverage I know he's not a
great tackle or can it be physical
I think his size allows him to be a
little bit more physical than when I at
least anticipated he's aggressive in
coverage he'll rub wide-receivers off
the route my favorite thing obviously is
the quickness to recover within the
route to close on the ball so CJ
Henderson here I compared him to trade a
via swipe in our draft 400 write-ups
that we're doing I think he's a really
really special corner if it weren't for
honestly for me if it weren't for Jeff
Okuda in this class I think we'd be
talking about CJ Henderson a lot more 21
the Philadelphia Eagles this is a team
that needs a wide receiver and number
three on the wide receiver board for me
is sitting here looking at them in the
face that is Henry Brooks and this is
just the steal at 21 he's gonna run in
the four twos at the combine but
anything you want on it but rugs is more
than that more than a speedster I think
he has great length with his catch
radius I think his routes really really
improved this year you can get him
involved on screens jet sweeps he does
so many things well and for the Eagles
getting a guy that threatens to stretch
the fields for Carson Wentz in this run
game is a must here they need more speed
at this position they simply need bodies
at this position rugs is a difference
maker from day one in Philadelphia it's
funny I get people who asked me like
well how do you use rugs like if you
watch the Superbowl use him like Tyree
Kill was used and you used him like debo
Samuel was used exactly the same thing
it's just the same dude and against a
little bit faster this is exactly what
Philly needs because they they
definitely need speed and he is the guy
to give you a ton of that number 22 the
Buffalo Bills there's gonna be a mini
run on receivers late first round and we
know what's coming the bills they need
sighs Josh Allen for all the things he's
done well it's still not the most
accurate quarterback on planet Earth so
you want a big catch radius for him to
go with the speed of coal Beasley and
John Brown t Higgins is that dude six
for 215 I think he is the best of the
round one guys when it comes to being
able to extend especially in the red
zone not necessarily be a jump ball guy
but be able to separate with size and
win
the top like T Higgins fits this well I
mean deep threat he's got it catch
radius he's got it and he does give you
a little bit above the turf in terms of
if Josh misses he's gonna be able to
save you
and he has some juice after the catch
that I did not see his first two years
at Clemson you know and this year he was
willing to grab the ball and run some
people over 23 the New England Patriots
maybe the best value pic of the entire
first round and of course that has to be
to them that is Derek brown from Auburn
and some people might be shaking their
heads here they go how does Brown fall
this far
it's a positional value thing here if
you look at the teams in the top 15 or
top 20 picks here a lot of them or most
of them need offensive line a pretty big
handful of them definitely need
quarterbacks there's always gonna be a
big value on the edge players and then
we didn't even get into how special the
top of this wide receiver class is so
when you're looking at the value of
defensive lines something that you can
go find in the middle tier a free agency
Derek brown is a better player than any
of those kind of guys I just don't know
if teams are gonna jump at the
opportunity to draft him and Kinlaw in
the top 10 top 15 picks but for New
England this is just a phenomenal player
Brown is technically refined he's a
disruptive player he has all the
production in the world that you need
playing all those years in the SEC and
he's done it against the best
competition level in college football
and I think a lot of times with early
mock drafts we're really looking heavy
at team needs and so like a Brown
doesn't go 7 to Carolina you do get into
a little bit of a spot of like God like
with the Jags take him at nine and then
there's a run on quarterbacks there's a
run on tackles and a guy like that falls
down the board so I mean he's top seven
on my board is not a knock on Derek
Brown the reason neither of us took him
until here number 24 the New Orleans
Saints it's a fascinating team because
we don't know Drew Brees as a free agent
technically all their quarterbacks are
agents breezes Bridgewater is taste some
Hills a restricted free agent we'll see
what tender they place on him basically
the way this works they can tender him a
first-round pick any team that wants him
would have to give New Orleans a
first-round pick in exchange they
contender him a second-round pick you
could do original round there's there's
different tenders and then the team that
signs him has to give you that in
exchange I've heard that they're gonna
tender him with a first or second round
pick so he should be expected to come
back what they need in this offense is
someone opposite Michael Thomas now
they're obviously doing just fine
with Mike catching 150 balls a year but
I think you would like to open things up
especially in the playoffs we've seen
three years now in a row they get to the
playoffs there when the hottest teams of
football they get bounced some of those
weren't their fault I understand that
but looking at the availability Justin
Jefferson fits this so well he just ran
their offense at LSU last year they had
a breakout season
I need Jefferson pointed mops at Mike
Thomas you have two amazing route
runners at this stage you've got some
speed guys already on the roster they
complement that well I jump for saying
it's just about as seamless as you can
get for a rookie wide receiver going
into an NFL offense and that's an
absolute no-brainer it's nice that
Michael Thomas might be on that Jerry
Rice pace right now but let's give the
guy a breather and get some help across
from him in this offense especially one
like you said Matt that might not be
playing with Drew Brees forever 25 the
Minnesota Vikings they need a corner
Jeff Gladney is to me the number two
corner in this class I love a speed I
love how he plays the football in the
air
I think he's feisty in coverage I love
everything about Jeff glad in his game I
wish we had gotten to see him up close
and personal at the Senior Bowl so for
the Vikings it's looked like it's just
about over for Xavier Rhodes it's tough
to say that but he just doesn't have his
legs underneath him anymore but you get
a guy that certainly does and that is
glad me love Jeff Gladney number 26 the
Miami Dolphins we've had them go
quarterback and tackle now I think they
can look at a lot of times these MOX
we've gone running back it's been kind
of a underreported a little bit what is
going on with Miami Dolphins corner
Xavier Howard and we'll wait to be very
underreported
we'll wait to see because you don't want
to point fingers too early but it's not
good potentially they could be looking
at corner even if saving Howard is back
I keep Talib is an older player they
really haven't gotten anything from
tankers leader they drafted in 1708
corner is a sneaky need for this team
christian fulton is still on the board
you get a guy who's physical can press I
think he has enough speed to play
a in-phase down the field unfortunately
this year he was just a little bit
banged up and again we didn't see him at
the Senior Bowl because the ankle injury
that happened in a national championship
game
I like folding a lot I know he's talked
to people around the league and they say
he's probably like a second-round guy I
think it's easy to say that you know
when you're sitting there on the clock
and the corners have come off the board
Henderson's gone glad he's gone and you
need a corner I think there's a good
chance Fulton goes late round one and
one thing with the Howard charges Matt
even though they were dropped this
weekend one thing Dolphins fans need to
understand is the league will still
conduct their own investigation and
we've seen a lot of suspensions even
after charges are dropped so I think
Corner is most definitely a very
important position for them 27 the
Seattle Seahawks he made a great point
to me before the show is jaren Reed is
going to hit free agency most likely and
Javon Kinlaw is on the board at 27
Kinlaw is the exhibit a of a Seattle
pick a guy that is just a bull in a
china closet you know maybe the
technique needs a little work but most
of the time it doesn't matter because he
just whoops the [ __ ] out of everyone in
front of him even double teams Kinlaw in
Seattle he's everyone's worst nightmare
and just such a no-brainer pick what he
can do
blowing up the run getting after the
quarterback I know we love talking to
him on this show he was unblockable down
in Mobile then he hurt his ankle got
back in there on one-on-ones won that
one-on-one and then his agent probably
gave him a call and said hey buddy
you're going in the first round get the
[ __ ] off the field so Ken's LA to
Seattle at 27 his buzzer went off you
know like listen man you're out air
sorry number 28 the Baltimore Ravens a
team I could see them go running back I
could see him go running back running
back corner receiver but I think edge is
gonna be a big need we'll see what
happens to mad you Don I think a
japanesse fits well here because he can
play five technique he could play inside
he can't stand up a rush a little bit
we've talked about epinet needing to be
someone where he can be versatile where
he can be a little bit of a chess piece
Baltimore is a great fit for him again a
player I have ranked quite a bit higher
than this he could go to Atlanta at 16
he go to Dallas at 17 but as he tumbles
down the board a little bit here the
Ravens get really really fortunate as
happens to them it seems like every year
for all
questions that I've personally had with
that Vanessa I do think he's one of the
higher floor players in the first round
because of his athleticism because of
his size and power so for the Ravens
they're at 28 I would feel very very
comfortable with that pig especially
like you said Matt we're gonna find out
what they do with Matt Sudan whether
they franchise and trade him whether
they try to make a deal work but either
way it's probably a spot that they will
look it to invest in in this first or
second or third round 29 the Tennessee
Titans once again free agency matters so
much for these mock drafts and we're
just gonna keep doing them if Derrick
Henry does leave in free agency which i
think is fully potentially on the table
there I'm gonna go with Jonathan Taylor
here from Wisconsin now I like DeAndre
swift better than Taylor there are
things that I like about JK Dobbins
better than Taylor but when you look at
the fit in this offense coming in
stepping in ready to be a 1500 yard back
from day one in this rushing attack I
think Taylor is a perfect fit in
Tennessee if they have to replace
Derrick Henry and he's gonna run a lot
better than people think at the NFL
combine
oh yeah like if he he's gonna be low
four fours and he's a four four guy
conservatively I liked the only thing I
don't like about Taylor or the fumbles
ensure if you take that away gosh she's
probably the best running back in the
class because he everything the vision
the power downhill speed character yet
characters great yep number 30 the Green
Bay Packers we talked to our guy Allen
Lazard about how you know they're gonna
add some receivers he's ready for it
Davante Adams is ready for it what they
need is speed Devante is a route runner
Lazard is a big guy they need speed they
need someone who can make plays with the
ball in their hands in this class that
is ylvis' Cochet know what he does after
the catch is special we were talking
about Brandon not you earlier in this
show Chanel I think he's a little bit
better version of that he's not gonna be
I don't think he's gonna be
exceptionally great straight-line speed
but his agility his quickness his vision
with the ball on his hands is really
special I know you and Melo up said it
before he might be a better running back
just get the ball in his hands he can
make things happen in Green Bay you're
not expecting him to be a great route
runner because you got that guy let him
be your number three receiver a little
bit of a gadget guy but just fine
touches for him I'm
I look at Chanel and it's I wish I think
something we should do on this show is
maybe stack players in a different way
like by categories like speed ability
after the catch and when you get in
through that ability after the catch
it's really like Chanel CD Lam and I uke
in the conversation and I love Jerry
judy and Henry rugs because of their
speed and explosiveness but when she not
lowers his shoulder that guy's just fly
off of him yeah it's really wild to
watch and and he has a fat nfl.com did a
really really nice story on his you know
a pretty crazy childhood his upbringing
what's molded him to make him the player
in person he is right now and I think in
Green Bay that is just a seamless fit
where you look at Adams chanel and Lazar
that's a really nice trio they're a
younger trio to develop around with
their older quarterback 31 the 49ers I
originally had Grant Delpit here I'm
gonna switch it up I went with Cesar
Ruiz from Michigan interior offensive
lineman he was a phenomenal Center this
year for Michigan I do think six for 320
he can play guard and he moves very well
for that size when you watch him against
Notre Dame his ability to get outside as
a pulling interior offensive lineman
opened up some huge run lanes with the
49ers I know Wesson Richburg has been
very very good his injury history right
now Matt is as significant as it gets
you have to wonder is he gonna be back
at full strength is he going to stay
healthy is the biggest question I have
so - give yourself insurance not only at
center but across your entire interior
offensive lineman for a guy that is not
only great size but a scheme fit with
Kyle
I love Ruiz's film and if he sneaks into
the retin the first round I would not be
shocked in the slightest bit yeah I
think he's the first renard if he
doesn't go 31 he could go 32 where the
Chiefs are selecting because he was gone
I went linebacker Patrick Queen I know a
lot of chief fans want a corner here I
didn't want to reach for an age eight or
L or jaylen Johnson or Cam Dan slur I
think the smart move is honestly to
trade back but with the board following
the way that it did Patrick Queen solves
a lot of your problems at linebacker
the Chiefs want speed we saw them bring
in Darren Lee but there were smart guys
with some bring in Reggie Ragland
anything he Hitchens is somewhere in the
middle of that I think they could use a
big upgrade here and as they start to
get up against the cap again with when
they're gonna have to pay mahomes
you got Tyree kill Frank Clark Tyrann
Mathieu Chris Jones is a free agent so
you got to start to get cheaper at some
positions I think in linebackers one
spot they could save some money
Patrick Queen he's a top 15 player I
think on my board so him here at 32
really good value for Brett Veatch and
the defending Super Bowl champion Kansas
City Chiefs we think Chris Jones is gone
right really starting to feel that way
even if it's a tagging trade of
something I wrote about on Friday in
this county notebook I think that yeah I
think it's a pretty good chance he's
gone I mean when you look at it when you
win a Super Bowl your players are gonna
get poached it happens and I think for
the Chiefs I don't want to call Chris
Jones expendable because he is
phenomenal but like all great teams have
to do there's gonna have to be some
tough decisions made making this this
first round are really interesting I
love Queen though love them good value
good fit let's take a break we have four
draft on draft questions for you coming
up after this it is draft on draft time
our guide am supa ask
listen likelihood the Niners get out of
the Jimmy G contract and pursue a
quarterback in the draft or a Cam Newton
as our resident Niners fan I'll say I am
a little bit more worried about Jimmy G
than I was because yeah when the game
got tight he folded a little bit no way
in hell this happens or should happen I
think that you look at the Niners right
now it's about John Lynch kasha Shanahan
Jimmy Garoppolo that is your identity
Jimmy would have been the MVP if my
home's hadn't pulled off the magic he
did or at least he or Bosa would have
been he was playing really well until
the fourth quarter I don't think you can
get out of that contract necessarily
number one even if you wanted to I think
he's better than Cam Newton who's been
hurt for a year and a half and he's 27
years old this was his first year coming
off an ACL tear and I know there's been
a lot of Jimmy can't get it done Jimmy
can't get it done he did all season and
I think it's just a matter of building
the help around him and then sometimes
you're gonna run into a [ __ ]
juggernaut and that's what my home is
yeah that's the problem there I mean if
Jimmy makes the one throw and the in the
fourth quarter there we're talking about
you know Super Bowl MVP Jimmy Garoppolo
and you know can the Niners repeat next
year and how good can this dynasty be
but unfortunately he didn't make the
throw now I like that our buddy dam supa
brings up the contract talk because I'll
say this it is very very flexible for
the Niners to get out of it you can get
a now yep they they basically can get
out now with very minimal dead money I
think they will go into this year with
Jimmy G as their quarterback I feel
pretty pretty comfortable about that if
things don't work out before the 2021
season the dead money hit is 2.8 million
dollars that is chump change in today's
NFL in terms of Dead Money hits
especially on a quarterback contract so
this year probably Jimmy's year if it
doesn't work out you're gonna hear the
Kirk cousin noise ramped up again
because we know how much Kyle values
Kirk Cousins and we know how much Kirk
Cousins values being somewhere
comfortable and safe for him so I think
when you look at it though we're looking
at Jimmy Garoppolo in the 2020 season
you know the the way the NFL works
though Brady goes to the Raiders like
you keep trying to make happen you know
Bella checks Colin be like hey I don't
want a little guy anyway what do you
shock me at all right and you know Jimmy
would go back there with Bill Bill's
obsessed with him so who knows I've been
a Niners fan long enough to know that
right when you think you have a dynasty
with Montana and young crazy things
happen and you end up with Jeff Garcia
and then you know it is what it is Pat
Chamberlain says is there any reality to
the rumors of Miami trying to trade up
to the number two pick if Miami jumps to
- do you think Detroit would still trade
down or were they staying at three and
takes re long question and take chase
young so I'll say this I think it's way
too early to do more than speculate
about trades like we keep saying now
Miami is probably gonna have to trade up
I think it's it's a little early and I
know where this question is coming from
because there was some noise on Twitter
someone reported that this trade was
happening I think it's a little too
early to say anything like that so it
my knee comes up too - the problem with
Washington is okay you're back down at
five and as we say always that means you
gotta have enough players that you like
at the spot so if that happens I think
Detroit just takes chase young that's
the easiest pick in the history of the
Lions franchise plug him in opposite
Trey flowers I have a hard time seeing
Washington want to trade back to five
because all the needs that this team has
especially if they can get Trent
Williams to come back there need I mean
they didn't edge rusher they need a
corner so it could happen it would
probably take all of Miami's picks would
be my thought that's the thing all their
persons sorry for Washington yeah it's
not gonna be cheap
number one Washington will have to face
the reality that chase young is going
through the Lions and then the Giants
will take either Jedrek wills Jeff Okuda
or Isaiah Simmons so for Washington at
five you need to you know feel
comfortable or love Jeff Okuda or Jedrek
wills enough where you're sitting there
saying hey you know Trent's gonna be
gone we're gonna have to trade them
maybe we get our second rounder back in
that trade we can replace him with
Jedrek wills or we replace Josh Norman
with Jeff Okuda they would really have
to love those guys to entertain this
trade offer because then you're the team
that passed on chase young that's the
issue that's what you worry about and I
think like chase young is not getting
talked enough about he's gonna blow icon
by and I think that will change he's
cooled off and I am so tired of the he
disappeard down the stretch talk no he
did not
it's just such a lie yeah such a lie so
I mean I think he's just so good that we
don't talk about him because if you
don't take him in with the second
overall pick you're insane yeah I
absolutely agree and again we've talked
about this a lot today I remember this
happening when Nick Bosa Myles Garrett
Joey Bosa you know our people oh by the
time the combine rolls around you forgot
how great they were
but teams will not forget Gary Greenlee
who do you think will great hire at the
end of the process
Darnell savage or Xavier McKinney for me
we'll be Savior McKinney I liked Darnell
savage a lot I mean he was had so much
speed playing free safety but it'll be
McKinney I'm trying to get my notes to
pull up it's about doing the same thing
where I had savage last year he wasn't
my top safety I want to say I remember
that being being the case I tailor rap
as my top safety then Johnathan Abram so
I had savage yeah he was like mid round
two for me so I don't see any way that
McKinney Falls that far on my board yeah
I had savage at 52 overall and I will
put the house on unless he runs a four
seven that McKinney will be much higher
than 52 overall and I'll be honest with
you Matt I was I think he's a good
player and I thought he definitely
flashed a lot this year I was a little
caught off guard when savage went as
high as he did almost ooh I really love
you I thought McKinney I'm sitting there
and I'm like oh my Kenny's going in the
first round I really thought Chauncey
Gardiner Johnson was more like that guy
like if you were gonna go with safety it
did have a great year or nasir Adderley
even I was kind of in that conversation
so now McKinney you'll be will be ahead
of that last question from Rob Griffith
can you see a scenario where Sean
McVeigh is on the hot seat and the Rams
are looking to move on from Jared Goff
at the end of next season I cannot
I think mcveigh's story's still burnin
bright for all the problems the Rams had
this year they still finished with a
winning season their pick is still
number 20 overall they were almost a
playoff team in a division that had the
NFC's number one seed in the NFC Seattle
was 11 and 5 they would have been the
number one seed in almost any other
division the Rams went 9 and 7
yeah they got a rebuild on the fly a
little bit with the old line I think my
face just fine and and I actually will
give him credit for revamping his staff
this year and saying alright we gotta
shake some things up because 9 & 7 is
not good enough for us I mean we talked
about before how the Jimmy G contract is
written to get out of it
the Jared Goff one is not so I they love
Sean McVeigh and if he was ever fired
from the Rams
he's so loved and valued by the league
teams would trade for him you wouldn't
even have to fire him you would get
something in return Shawn McVeigh so
that's not happening with guff I think
he's gonna have the reins there for at
least two more years so in 2022 is dead
money's ten million at that point of the
the lead contracts you could swallow
that money but the Rams are one of those
teams that they don't really have enough
picks where you go oh well they'll take
a take a guy that could challenge rough
like like how Gardner Minshew came out
of nowhere last year like will they take
a mid round guy and hope that he could
challenge Goff I don't think they have
enough picks to even do that no I think
they're gonna do everything they can to
make this bad boy work there I think
that's what I was waiting to hop in on I
think more so they are understanding the
limitations of Goffman they'll try to
cover that up with bigger receivers or
you know whatever the case might be and
I think their problems were not just
Jared Goff Todd Gurley fell off a cliff
the offensive line did not play well I
mean losing Roger Saffold and Sullivan
at center that was huge for them and we
want to put all the blame and all the
praise on quarterbacks when they're good
but man I really feel like when you look
at them it's not not just golf he wasn't
great but it wasn't just on him all
right that is our show for today we will
be AK Wednesday morning hopefully have
an update on Tua's CT scan we're gonna
fix a team and we're gonna go heavy on
draft on draft so send in those drafts
on draft questions whether it's on
Twitter in your Apple podcast review
however you want to do it hit us up will
do will do like ten of them oh wait yeah
we got a lot of in there in the review
so if you left an iTunes review recently
that's gonna be the ketchup show for all
of those questions and knowing how the
NFL works I'm sure in these next 24
hours there will be some bombshell news
at some point exactly something will
happen
what really cuts should start happening
this week so there will be some news but
we'll be back in 24 hours we'll talk to
you guys real soon